failed former president Donald Trump
gave an interview to oan's channel Ryan
which should be a very very friendly and
positive interview she brought up nfts
AKA Trump's recent grift of selling nft
digital trading cards sorry I can't even
do it with Steve Bannon said is not good
that Trump should not be doing it that
whoever came up with the idea should be
fired she brings it up to him and Trump
basically says he thought the nfts were
cute
um this should have gone well and it did
not go very well let's take a listen to
this I'm asking you as as Donald Trump
the money man I mean you have invested
your life in tangible assets and so the
question is are you looking at nfts as
this kind of this new world of
cryptocurrency that is Sir is the new
world for the physical asset guy Trump
who did Real Estate now digital trading
cards is this the future of money
or is it just you're playing with it
I viewed it differently I didn't view it
as investment I viewed it as I thought
they were cute I mean
oh God
the former president thought the nfts
were this channel this is not an
investment okay but this is definitely
definitely not an investment it's just
cute for 99 you're getting these these
visions that are very beautiful and
interesting I think yes me wearing a
spacesuit for 99 bucks it's so it's just
cute and I viewed it that way much more
so than as an nft yeah but nft as you
know was very hot two or three years ago
nft is hot it cooled down you know it's
a category that happens it cooled down
so when they announce it's nft everyone
said what's he doing that for that's so
cold it was it was the reaction of many
that's true and uh I did it and I guess
it was one of the most successful maybe
the most successful but it was certainly
in terms of speed the whole thing was
sold out almost immediately
this imagine if we had said in 2016
in the next six years Donald Trump will
win a Republican primary
defeat Hillary Clinton in a general
election
uh do all the insane stuff he did for
the four years
then lose to Joe Biden in 2020. claim
that he won wage a two-year War during
which he grifts tens of millions from
his followers to supposedly overturn the
results support a bunch of candidates
who lose in 2022 and then sell nft
digital trading cards and appear on oan
to say that they're cute
nobody would have believed that
absolutely nobody would have believed in
fact I can't think of a single person
who would have taken that bet and uh it
is really really something else to see I
agree in a sense with Steve Bannon that
the entire Trading Card thing is
completely humiliating but the truth is
Trump does humiliating things all the
time and so I don't know that it's
uniquely humiliating it'll be
interesting to see if it where what the
next thing is and the the hypothesis
that is increasingly forming is Trump
may be realizing that this 2024 run is
not going to go well
and if and when Trump starts to believe
that he may end up having to bail before
the first primaries as some have have
suggested may happen he is going to go
into grift mode which is what is the
most amount of money I can pull out of
this before I quietly go away and say
that's the end of my political career
and then this starts to make sense which
is what is just on this side of the law
that I can use to pick up a few extra
million
um before I just kind of quietly go away
and if you look at it in that sort of
framework with that idea then the nft
thing makes a lot of sense so even Trump
not really making sense in trying to
explain why he did the nft thing there's
nothing cute about them uh but that's
the explanation that he's giving at this
point in time